Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P
The Eggman called in about the Buffalo terrorist
shooting and right wing media. The egg man says
there's not been a lot of coverage of it on right
wing media. Maybe a lot of right wingers won't
even know it happened. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hi, Dave. So that mass shooting
that occurred in Buffalo, New York, is kind of
close to my house, you know, not very close,
but in the area. So I watched on the news
regularly since it happened. And I'm I'm sorry,
but I paid for Fox News and all the right wing
news channels also because I have no Internet.
Speaker 1: By the way, there's really if you have
cable, there's really no way not to pay for Fox.
Fox isn't a channel where you can say, I don't
want it. So unfortunately, any of us who have
a cable subscription, you have no choice but to
pay for Fox News. And that's that's a real shame.
Speaker 3: All right. I have to get cable. So
I flip back and all the news channels and the
only one carrying it, well, the only ones are the
so-called left wing liberal channel, CNN, MSNBC.
And I do have like Newsmax and News. Now there's
other right wing news channels. Did you ever hear
about news now? It's wholly owned. Anyway, none
of those channels were carrying the shooting.
And I went. I would go out and come back to my
house all weekend long. I just kept checking.
None of the right wing channels were covering
the mass shootings, the racist mass shooting in
Buffalo, New York this morning. I turn the news
to go to work and I did see it on Fox and Friends
a little bit. Do you think that the left wing
media is showing it too much or the right wing
media is avoiding it because a white guy
kill black people? It's obviously racist.
What's going on, Dave? Shalom.
Speaker 1: All right. Yeah.
Shalom to the egg, man. No, this. So,
so a couple of different things. One.
In the first 48 hours after such an incident. It
is major news and it makes sense that it would be
covered. I don't think the media outlets covering
it are covering it too much. There is one other
thing going on on the right. A lot of stations are
very minimally covering it or not covering it at
all because of the obviously right leaning, great
replacement theory, racist, white, nationalist,
neo-Nazi motivations of the shooter. But we've
also seen, as we looked at earlier in the show,
Fox News doing the well, you know, violent
video games might be what's to blame here.
And Fox News talking about, oh, terrorists
might come through the southern border from
other countries, but what about the domestic
terrorists that's here and that killed ten people?
So the what the right wing media outlets that
are covering it are covering it in a completely
dishonest way. I don't know what's worse, not
covering it at all or covering it in a way that
completely distorts people's understanding of it.
But the ag man's conclusion is accurate. People
who only get their news from right wing media
if they know about the mass shooting in Buffalo
are going to have a very skewed perspective on
what it is that took place. And we'll talk about
this more on today's bonus show. This is terrible
news. Pennsylvania U.S. Senate candidate John
Fetterman has suffered a stroke but says that he's
well on his way to a full recovery. This is the
primaries tomorrow. Okay. So we're going to talk
about that. Mitch McConnell says that the Senate
is going to pass the largest Ukraine aid package
ever on Wednesday. And lastly, Elon Musk says that
the Twitter legal team came to him and said, sir,
you violated an NDA, a nondisclosure agreement.
What's that all about? And what's happening
with Musk purchasing Twitter? I still I didn't
think it was going to happen and I still don't
think it will. All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. Get access to the bonus show
today by signing up at join Pacman dot com or
get access to the bonus show at a discount on
Monday, May 30th. That's Memorial Day. Memorial
Day. There will be no new show will be off for the
holiday, but we will be doing a one day membership
special. If you've been thinking, maybe I'll get
a membership. I don't know. The perfect day. The
best day to sign up is Monday, Memorial Day. Just
get on our newsletter at David Pakman dot com. And
in the morning on Memorial Day, you'll
get an email telling you how to sign up.